let's get Ron in here and talk about
space hi Ron welcome to the show welcome
Ron Livingston hello thank you how's it
going man good all right look
as we're sure you know there's a big
science announcement coming at 10:00
a.m. they do a giant announcement
something about gravity and we don't
know what it is well we're all on the
edge of our seats cause we were trying
to do the show and then Troy pulled up
on the computer that there's a big
gravity announcement coming at 10:00
a.m. and Jim has been thoroughly
distracted that's true since he found
out there is a gravity announced Ron
your feelings on gravity go I this is
gonna be I know exactly what this is
gonna be Oh what do you think I think
it's gonna be the gravity way the
gravitational wave detection experiment
I think they've had one confirmation on
it and this is I think gonna be a
gravitational wave event that was
probably picked up on maybe by two or
three different sites no gravitational
wave what do you mean by that
yeah we don't know what that mean you
know gravity propagates in in waves
right is the theory by the way that he
said right you could have said it never
propagates the waves and he went right
he just said there's no idea if you're
right or wrong no yeah I'm checking you
he's right that's correct so far so yeah
so I think the you know the idea again
this is now yours a layman's understand
of us already yeah yeah so that you have
something that's that's very dense and
very massive and you know black hole or
something like that that it's gonna
propagate waves out and those waves are
gonna interfere with each other in a way
that you're gonna have little crests and
little troughs and gravity so at any
point in time I believe and again this
is I could be giving bad science to the
world at the moment um that I believe
what they're detecting is a little
fluctuation in the Grattan gravitational
field itself which would confirm that
that this is actually the way that you
know gravity propagates but the ELCA in
waves in way but they'd really don't
know that for a fact that it moves in
other they're just now kind of going yet
does moving waves gravity it's one of
those things because it's so
it's really hard to detect I think at
that at that level you know
electromagnetism we always think his
gravity at being this really powerful
force but it's only because you know
like the earth is so big that that we
you know it's pulling us down that hard
um think of it if it was a magnet that
was that was that big you know what I
mean and we were like a like think how
hard it would pull you down then so grab
it you know gravity's actually I think
the weakest of the when did you start
learning about science I was a kid not
you Jim my my grandfather was a
chemistry physics teacher oh my god you
understand physics I can't get I can't I
know I look like I would understand if I
don't I would I'm gonna have to say I'm
gonna have to say no I kind of
understand it on in layman's terms but I
don't think he the the mathematical
truth of it I don't think I you know I'm
not fluent well Neil deGrasse Tyson I
have sparred and I know there's that
thing where they call when these two UH
two particles will react to each other
but they're further away where the
information has to travel faster than
the speed of light quantum entanglement
uh yeah there you go
quantum entangled one like one does this
the one does that and yet the
information had to travel yeah faster so
I thought this gravitational announce
was going to be something too at the
speed of light I was incorrect there's
been obsessed with the speed of light
and every time the under grass tyson has
come in here he tries to argue with him
that we will travel faster than the
speed of light and breast eyes and says
we will not I know yeah
as much as I I know Einstein's a bright
guy right I just don't believe that one
guy on a chalkboard figured all of it
out in the 30s I'm sorry I just don't
believe that billions of years of
physics and I don't believe that a
civilization has been here four billion
years couldn't have gone beyond some
beautiful I figured out just on a
chalkboard yeah yeah do you think we're
gonna go faster than the speed of light
I I would say sign by the way all the
way I put it as the at current signs say
no yes right sign you know everything
points to the fact that it's that's just
the laws of physics sure work
there's a speed limit they found out Jim
also earlier food referred to the laws
of physics as rules of thumb I did yeah
we have to look at it when you look at
it we are going by what we have like
what we have right now is very advanced
to us but look back at say what cavemen
had to look at these two maestro so
we're gonna look at our times right now
as primitive in the thousand years from
now we're gonna go those guys equipment
was [ __ ] well where'd I don't know what
thousand years they couldn't even see
the beginning of the of time they
couldn't even see the Big Bang now we
could see that on our iPhone whatever it
is you think I still have iPhones
nobody'll be able to go back and watch
it sure we'll figure out a way to film
events at the past you know you
understand alright Ron welcome to the
show people hate when I talk science I'm
all over the place yeah I'm talking
about I'm just guessing I like it yeah
so your grandfather was a physicist did
you have any desire to do anything like
that or use chemistry and physics
teacher so I mean he was a lot of things
but he was an educator yeah you know I
didn't I loved it I loved studying it my
I think I took a semester of fixing the
physics in college and I said yeah I
think I'm gonna be an actor was it too
hard or just boring for you it was too
early in the morning it was I think it
was 8:00 a.m. up on Science Hill so I
was a mile and a half away yeah I think
it just did you know I I got to a place
where I was like I think I'm gonna let
my science my physics education anyway
rest for a bit I just be an actor
because I should be an act all the
science class is the first thing in the
morning the popular science books and
somebody can break it down to me in
English
yeah make sense you start to give acting
in college I did I mean I started you
know I was doing like school plays in
six sixth grade so yeah I'd been acting
I think College was the first time I was
I took an acting class
and you know came to the realization
like oh I've been doing this all wrong
you know right go to the class but you
realize like you don't know what you
know I have no idea no wow there's
actually a you know there's a skill you
can learn
um yeah so I started at that point and
have been going ever since
so your mom was a Lutheran pastor your
father was it was a narrow space you
finally kind of followed at least in the
intellectual things of his dad he became
an aerospace engineer mom's dad my mom's
a physics teacher my dad's dad was a
Salesman but ya know my dad was was an
engineer has recently retired yeah I
think he he just had that math mind and
and I won't say that he enjoyed it I'm
probably you know he he sort of gave me
permission to choose any career I wanted
except engineering why do you want to do
it I think he just he didn't love it you
know he liked the work he just I don't
know there was something about it maybe
he was just grumpy okay no I mean you
don't you'd be better at it sometimes
you know the father doesn't the son of
me better than he does
maybe or or he didn't want you to do it
and it might have been kidding too but I
didn't want you to do it and enjoy it
right cuz like if you hate your job you
want it it's the job it's done you want
to save your kid from the thing even if
the thing you're doing is awesome you
want to save yourself having to answer a
million questions about the thing coming
up dad what a bad leg off [ __ ] I want
to hear this anymore - if you're the
intern lives in your house now I can go
home the the announcements on let's just
chop it other way balls chime in here
for a second yeah deputy US chief
technology officer NSF a thing and
Federico
Farini alright there's too many people I
don't I don't need the [ __ ] people
around tell me what's happening with
gravity yeah let me know is you're right
though is gravity still a thing yes
yeah - Harvey Stone we can't fly no we
can't fly right it's a boring ripple
announcement no one gives a [ __ ] I try
to tell you this when you first start
talking about I know but I believe Ron
not you oh I see he's no reason to lie
to me I got that's true
wouldn't mislead you yes you would see
your mama's it was a pastor yes she
actually that's the second career for
her so she she went to seminary about
the same time that my little sister went
to college she you know had raised three
or four kids and and my baby brother was
about 11 or 12 and I think it was
something that she'd always had felt a
calling to and then just gave herself
permission to go and do it and but they
don't like pastors don't have like vows
of celibacy right that's like priests
and nuns but pastors gonna have families
right yeah I think only I don't think
any of the Protestant orders have have
vows of celibacy so we you religious
growing up yeah I I would say yeah we
were raised
we were raised you know we were raised
Lutheran although it's a my mom's flavor
of it is a very it's a very liberal you
know what I mean it's a very sort of
open-minded version of it even as a
pastor yeah especially especially as a
pastor it's really it's kind of amazing
actually it's amazing to see like I
started the first couple times I went to
her services she has a very personal
connection with everything and and it's
like she's she's kind of doing a
philosophical exploration for herself
that's filtered through you know the the
church and it's it's so much it's so
much I guess more engaging and when I
grew up with which was sometimes they
get a little bit of that but then a lot
of times it was people lecturing you I
don't know much about being Lutheran
what's the difference in that and just
being like Christian what's the what's
the big [ __ ] the big sweat split it's
German it's like northern German is one
of the four it was kind of the first
branch off I think from the it was like
a reformist church try to take the money
I was trying to drain the swamp get the
money out oh okay you know there's a
stern Scandinavian branches of it but
it's uh it's you know it's a sort of
it's a fairly
liberal tradition because it started in
as a reformist movement okay I know
nothing do you a million of them do you
uh bring do you raise your family
religious now or because you were kind
of raised yeah you got yeah I mean I
think what you do is you the rule of
thumb that is I want to give my kids the
the tools to be able to discover and
explore it for themselves and I want to
answer like if they ask me questions
about things I'm gonna answer it as
truthfully as it can't I can according
to what I believe with you know with the
[Music]
while also giving the information of
like and that's just my two cents
because you some people think this and
some people think that and what do you
think you know and I think that's the
way to to to engender kind of a lifelong
connection to it rather than like a
dogmatic right it's kind of amazing the
amount of viewpoints you must have
around you because if your mom's dad
it's like a physics chemistry teacher
yeah and then your mom is a pastor like
those are the two opposite ends right
you generally find that people who teach
science like like all the other
scientists that we hear from you know
sort of in pop culture these days or
also have this kind of atheist undertone
to them yeah you would think I think
that's maybe a more recent development
in recent meaning since Galileo you know
but I I don't think they're actually
they come from the same place which is
philosophy and trying to understand the
world that we live in you know and they
definitely I think take two different
paths of trying to come to that but I
think it's it's because they they're
exploring different things you know yeah
science is trying to look in a look at
all the things that we can measure and
and deduce everything we can about what
we can measure you know and and I think
religion is looking at everything else
that we can't measure
and science would say well if you can't
measure it you can't say anything about
it you can't you know you then you have
to just say I don't know I can't measure
it I don't know anything and that's
absolutely true from a scientific
perspective but it it means there's a
whole you know a bunch of other
experiences like that you don't ever get
to talk about or think about you you
have to come up with other other terms
to do it and I think religion offers
that yeah ok so you found a way to do
both yeah yeah spirituality I would say
spiritual so when you when you get into
acting is like comedy what you what you
want to do or is it what you happen to
make your first it was a break-in yeah
it was the path the path of least
resistance yeah yeah I stumbled into it
it's one of those things where when I
first got to LA you were either doing
like spelling shows you know the if you
were really good looking you could go do
the spelling shows and if you weren't
you were looking you were trying to get
a couple lines on a sitcom the two
things that in the early 90s that those
are that's what the king of what was on
TV and that's where were you were gonna
break in I was never quite good enough
to do the spell right off but I couldn't
buy it I mean I would I had been like a
theatre you know a straight theatre guy
and people really he's not funny he's
not funny there's nothing funny about so
it's it's only when you get your first
thing you know for me it was I think
swingers and then from swingers I did a
I did a sitcom it switches and then all
of a sudden it's like well he's a
comedian he can't do serious roles right
and it was a real fight to to try to get
something like you know Band of Brothers
finally broke that right but before that
you know but now I'm really you know so
I've always tried to do a whole bunch of
different things but this one I I really
it's it's a comedy throwing through but
that doesn't mean I don't get to bring
the rest of the stuff right away you
know I mean Loudermilk is a it's a it's
a half hour comedy and it's kinda it's a
peat thoroughly half hour comedy too so
it's it's
you know it's we take the gloves off but
it's also it's a comedy about rehab you
know it's a comedy about recovery which
is it's you know that's a serious topic
with a lot of stakes for some people and
you also do you keep in touch with bill
burr you know because you're in town I
remember bill to town he's a Molly
Ringwald sitcom and I'm 90 so I can't
that was 20 years ago 20 years ago
brother yeah love that guy I love that
guy
I never seen him you know I never see
him and it's and I always tell myself
you know oh it was gonna be at the Laugh
Factory I gotta go I gotta get tickets
together to that Factory and I never do
but the great thing is that he's
everywhere now so it's like you know I
still get to see him but look lovely guy
man lovely again what was it can I ask
you this what does some folks call it a
Sling Blade
it was a short you did what was yeah and
into it the film are know yeah it did it
was before Billy Bob made the movie he
made a short and so the short is
basically everything that happens in the
movie up until the opening credits it's
the scene in the asylum
he gives the speech talks about his
mother gets his papers walks out the
door and then that's the end of the
short and who are you in that I am an
orderly walking outside the room that
the I'm an extra basically I'm an extra
so I think maybe I can see myself in one
of the shots I'm not sure but since I
was there that day they were kind enough
to put me in the credits that's pretty
awesome that was JD whilst I was at the
speech he made to jet he washe it was no
it's it wasn't JT wasn't there it was he
made it to Molly Ringwald of all things
played the the nurse at the you should
all I thought you're joking no huh you
know it's Molly Ringwald she wasn't in
the film though was not in the film no
of course you know and then Billy Bob
went to do the film
and you know
cast it with people who do films rather
than people who do shorts so that great
it was a very fun thing and then when I
you know did the show with Molly to go
you know I've actually met you and on
the short and she was like huh you know
what is great about Loudermilk I was
watching the first handful of episodes
or whatever yesterday and we're friends
were Brian Regan oh and like you you you
wait and you wait for Brian Regan to not
be Brian Regan if you want to get Brian
Regan assessment of how to properly blow
a guy for drugs this is the show yeah he
finally gets out of Brian Regan and
talks about whether to whether whether
to stimulate the balls or the shaft I
can't remember which side he comes down
on because he is he's an advocate of the
shaft I think right I believe but look
you'll have to watch to find out yeah
honestly it is a tough question I mean
the tough cause you want it you want to
tease a little bit you want to make them
want more like before they give you the
drug maybe they'll give you the drugs
before you have to commit to the act
right here start with the balls okay
your expert advice about Brian man I we
were doing a sag panel Brennan was in
there but and Pete sort of dropped this
bomb he was like Brian Regan he's you
know there's probably the best stand-up
comic working today
and uh and uh and you know he's never
acted before and I just about fell out
of my chair because I I had no idea that
he you know that he had never acted
before and usually that's something that
you kind of pick up when yeah but man no
he just dropped right into it I want to
show years ago maybe he don't no way
yeah he's never done anything Wow major
really when you find out that is Peter
Farrelly was obviously attached to it
when you found out about it was that
like a big thing that's like okay yeah
I'll do this oh yeah yeah I mean yeah
absolutely it was because right away you
you know he you go okay I'm working with
kind of a comedy master right at the
same time like I was a little hesitant
not hesitant in doing it but I was a
little like gosh I wonder if this is
gonna work because
the stuff that you know I think I'm that
I think of in my head on on Petes stuff
is kind of not the stuff I'm good at
it's not the stuff I do like I always
try to underplay everything and make it
all kind you know like like that like
dry and peach stuff is not dry right so
it's it's I really like the way that it
kind of came together it's there's a you
know there's a lot of both of us that's
that's in the heart and soul of this
thing it's got to feel good too because
like you said like you're able to do a
comedy now knowing that like you've got
dramatic work on the table that's like
super you know people are super aware of
so it's not something where you're gonna
be trapped how long after office space
was it that you were not just getting
you know [ __ ] funny guy in the office
it was it was banner brothers I think so
it wasn't you know it was a couple of
years it wasn't too long but I mean
there was a minute where after office
space people were interested in doing a
show with me and they bring me in to
pitch me a sitcom and I'd say what I'd
really like to do is this you know
dramatic hour and then and then their
eyes would kind of glaze over and they
go okay nice - nice to meet you so of
course I understand you know but I
joined up getting Band of Brothers meg
Lieberman was the casting director on it
we I'd done a movie for her and I had
back to the science thing I'd auditioned
five or six times for from the earth to
the moon which was Tom Hanks series that
you know that she had done because I you
know as a kid I kind of liked the space
program and I really wanted to go be a
part of that there was never a part for
me at least not one that I could get but
I think she just saw you know she had
seen me audition enough that she was
like let's give a shot and I happen to
look like the guy that was that was
probably definitely helped pretty happy
for 70 yeah Wow man and and and so when
when office space like takes off like it
did yeah it's it kind of like
mind-blowing cuz I would imagine when
you start this project nobody associated
is thinking like oh this is going to
make every
buddy yeah it it was it was a slow burn
right you know it was like it was like
okay before it came out you know it's
like going up the hill at the roller
coaster you know it click like like like
like like like like and you're going oh
my god oh my god okay this is gonna be
amazing this is gonna be what a ride
this is gonna be oh so when you're
making it you're like this is actually
really good as is as its as its getting
closer to come out you know and you're
like that's a studio that's gonna be you
know my life is gonna change and then
with office stick base in particular
it's kind of like the roller coaster got
to the top and then stopped you know
right like it just kind of stopped cuz
nobody went to the movie nobody saw it
and radiators right and that was it and
then we sat up on the on the at the top
of the hill there for you know six seven
months a year and a half waiting for you
and Jennifer Aniston it might come and
get us down and then I would say that
once it started on Comedy Central it did
take off but it it was like a roller
coaster that takes three or four years
to actually make it tracks how long did
it before you really so like this is
kind of a classic comedy now um years it
was you yeah it was years it was
something really slow it'd be something
like huh I I you know like somebody at
the airport spotted me that I wouldn't
like nobody's oh yeah it was it was kind
of new like that and yeah there's also
when DVDs got really popular he's it was
it was it was I think one of the first
it was one of the first movies that
demonstrated that the model of doing
almost nothing in the theaters but going
going gangbusters in on DVD and cable
yeah could generate the studio's a lot
of money yeah so I got a lot of you know
people were a little bit usually if you
can't open a movie then people are like
kind of dead dude right a little bit but
I think this one made it a little
different did you read any regrets like
you said that you would go into these
meetings you'd say you want to do like
an hour-long
drama and they want to do a comedy with
he did you kind of ever regret just
going nah she's just kind of with what
they did no I I mean no the other I
would say to the other way around I the
stuff I regret is where I I didn't I
didn't take bigger bigger risks oh okay
bigger bigger chances now like these
days like I didn't know if I was gonna
be able to pull off Loudermilk I didn't
know if this character was something
that was gonna work for me you know with
me doing it and you know 20 years ago I
might not have taken it because I I was
a little more kind of I have to know you
know I was in my head a little bit I
have to know in my head how I'm gonna
say these lines and I have to guarantee
that it's going to be funny or otherwise
I don't want to do it and so I look back
on a lot of jobs that that I think you
know maybe I could I took could have
gone after that one or I could have said
yes to that if and and me and it might
it probably would have tanked or it
could have been terrible but there's
something there's a real freedom that
comes after you've made a couple of
terrible things and and you realize that
the world doesn't end right you see that
wasn't so bad
yeah we just we just made a terrible
movie that's you know what's the risk
that you could have taken but didn't
like what's one that you look back on
and god you really should have done that
one well I never I never really bit off
the thing of like developing developing
material you know I don't know it's hard
it's hard to say I'm trying to remember
of a specific thing it's not it's they
tend to be the things that you like shy
away from and don't even go after so
it's not even the stuff that you get
rights on you know to get close on it
you have to be pursue it yeah pursue and
be going after it but yeah
will you actively seek out stuff now or
they come to you and go look we have an
offer for you
or is just something you'll hear about
you go [ __ ] it I want to do that and I
want please get me in for it both I have
I you know have reps who are constantly
pitching me to you know for jobs that no
one's ever going to give me
because that's you know cuz because
maybe someday they will sure
and yeah and they're also fielding like
a lot of offers on stuff that I'm
probably never gonna do so it's really
about finding something in the sweet
spot that where it's like you're excited
about it and then you know oh my god who
could think that they're excited about
it on the other side - and now sudden
we're doing it
have you asked to go in on anything like
I know I'll be good at this and all the
sudden you [ __ ] the bed oh I mean yeah
all the time
oh I have a actually have a you know I I
auditioned for and now because your self
tape now a little bit yes cost me you
have to put yourself on tape and and
just do do with your I feel it in I do
do it I do do it with my iPhone I used
to do it a little flip video camera but
now it's just easier to do it the iPhone
or I have a DLSR that you know but
that's it's so I don't know how to use
it very well so I stick to the iPhone
generally but I I did a audition for the
clown in it for penny wise right and I
had to self tape that at home and uh you
know and the thing I was like well I
guess I have to go for it because I
don't know I feel like an idiot standing
here like being a scary clown unless I
look like a scary clown so I've got this
video of me in my basement
you know in like clown makeup fright wig
on or whatever doing like the the
Pennywise scene what did what did the
voice sound like it was a little he was
a little bit like that it was a head a
little Bill Murray it you know that's
it's something that I really told me
yeah just a pervy old man that was you
know a predator yeah it was I'm sure
they looked at it and we're like okay
well how is it make it what did you do
it to make it was anything without you
different than his what did you do with
it it was a little scared me I was it
was more in the realm of scary mime okay
they had it was a little bit like scary
mime clown rather
and scary Ringling Brothers clown have
you thought about putting it out on
YouTube just because yes you know I
don't think I think there's a trademark
issue where you're not supposed to do
that oh I really get mad that the movies
already a hit all you do is say
understand is Pennywise audition that's
not gonna hurt the movie people like I
gotta see this they talk about the movie
audition are you crazy
so then when you see it right and you
see penny wise it couldn't be more
different from the thing that you did in
your audition does it make you feel I'm
not gonna go see that they lost the Ron
Livingston dollars but when you find out
then when you find out that the choice
that they made was completely different
than what you did does that feel better
or or worse it feels great it's always
great you know it's there's all
everybody's got the experience of like
man I almost had this part and then
somebody did it and it turned out to be
a great thing but and if I had done it
then I'd be the one that got to do that
great thing but you forget the part
where is like except I might have
actually sucked in it which is maybe why
I didn't get it or wanted in the first
place right here I mean so to me if
somebody does something good it only
gives me hope that it's possible to like
do something good and I'm in an inner
performance because you know every once
in a while you start to think we all
suck you know and then somebody comes in
and just blows you out of the water and
you get hyped up about wow okay I'm
because that's possible cuz that's
possible yeah yeah like if somebody's
really kind of bringing their a-game in
it and you just have to Beach raises the
bar you have to be out of you you have
to have enough self-esteem to look at
that and not go like oh that's possible
that means I just suck as opposed to
being like oh that's possible that means
I can get there right I yeah
and again I don't know if this is stuff
that I that I came to or just people who
don't feel that way have to get out of
the business cuz is it it would make
them crazy otherwise but I've always
been somebody that if you know if I'm up
for a job and I don't get it I'm like
okay so I guess I got the month off you
know all right you know let me know when
you get the next one
what kind of wake did you wear I
remember it was like a purple I had to I
had a couple of them that I auditioned
one was like the like a purple rainbow
only thing and then when I don't
remember I'd have to go and look at it
again because I can't remember which one
I picked I tried them both and I don't
remember which one I actually sent how
did you say we all float we all float
down oh you'll float yeah it was
you float I liked it yeah I'm frightened
what are you doing boy
ice I've seen black and platinum who did
you play on black Empire I played a guy
named Roy I play basically a Pinkerton
Detective that sets up Gretchen Maul to
to elicit her confession was that season
four or five one of the policies it was
second to the last season I think six or
seven there was that many Boardwalk
Empire seasons oh yeah something like
that yeah I was on season seven or seven
I don't think I meant next to last to
last I didn't realize was that many
Jesus yeah now when you is that because
like you do Band of Brothers is there
like does HBO tend to hire the same
groups like once you're once you're
involved you do well on one HBO show a
little bit a lot of potential for other
stuff it's a it's a corporate thing like
wants somebody else in the company has
taken the risk of hiring somebody you're
you're on a list that if someone else
hires you now and it all falls apart
they can go what Bob hired in one that's
right he was great yeah you know and
right so you know it's it's a decision
someone's probably not gonna get fired
for it is funny how they do think that
where they want they people want to make
sure that the decision has kind of
amazed
they're not the one that's gonna tell ya
right why wouldn't they yes it's it's
25% is he good for the role in 75% is my
ass gonna be covered I guess fine
doesn't worry that I will be fired
because of this particular decision and
they got to make those decisions all day
long so you know you got a conservative
have you had primarily good
relationships with directors and people
you've worked with I mean the us hear
the horror stories about the one or two
I think so you know what I mean if I
haven't I've been clueless to it they
may you know they may be like going oh
geez a guy but I I've always I like I
like directors I like people who I mean
I like people who do this I like people
that get excited about this goofy you
know this goofy little thing yeah yeah
there's something it's just like a
fellow a fellow nerd in a particular
flavor so I yeah I love it I think that
like some of the some of the best like I
feel like office space and boardwalk and
Band of Brothers and probably some of
the other stuff I'm forgetting the thing
that they have in common is that they're
all like super authentic to the world
that they're portrayed in like even
office space which is just a goofy
comedy like it wouldn't work if it
wasn't super authentic office humor how
quickly on a project do you realize like
this is not authentic to this world can
you see that in a script is it once you
get on the set is it not till the movie
gets made usually you see that in the
script yeah like if the script is bad
it's really hard to make a good movie
like if if if you're reading a script
you like well know people don't talk
they I wanted to say that they don't
talk like that
if if on the page people sound like
people right I'm talking to each other
in a way that people talk to each other
it gives it's just a great a it's a
great start because those are the lines
you're saying but it also says that okay
so whoever greenlit this has good taste
as far as that goes and whoever is
directing it and signed on to it that
must be the kind of stuff they want to
do and I there's just it's hard for me
to get hired on other stuff I think
because you know because I had this sort
of like really laid-back
like a low-energy thing that if they
wanted the guy that was going to come
and be like hey you know doing the thing
even when I tried to do that it just
they it doesn't feel right I wouldn't
get hired yeah they were like yeah then
we're not gonna hire that guy for that